تطبيق اصبح كالهواء الذين تلبسوه بين
الاهل والاصحاب والاهم في العمل فمن منا
لا يستخدم الواتساب الذي يبدو ان رنه
واتساب الشهيره لن تسمع بعد اليوم في بنك
مرجان ستان الامريكي الشهير حيث فرض احد
اكبر البنوك الامريكيه غرامه على موظفيها
الذين يستخدمون التطبيق او اي منصات تواصل
اجتماعي مع العملاء فبحسب التقرير ان
البنك فرض غرامه قد تصل الى مليون دولار
على الموقف الذي يخالف هذه القواعد
الجديده البنك الامريكي كان قد تعرض
لغرامك كبيره من لجنه الاوراق الماليه
الامريكيه بعد تحقيقات تخص الاتصالات
مماثله بالعملاء عبر منصات التواصل ويعود
ذلك الى ان هذه اللجنه الامريكيه المتخصصه
تفرض على البنوك تتبع الاتصالات الرقميه
للموظفين الخاصين بها ما يعني انها تعرف
جميع المكالمات التي يقومون باجرائها
[موسيقى]
من عمان الى عباد القمر خبير الامن
السيبراني يسعد صباحك استاذ عباده اهلا بك
معنا في صباح العربيه
الله يسعد صباحكم جميعا
غرامه تعد الاكبر تخص شركه ماليه الا اما
ده وما هي حدود التعامل ماليا عبر واتساب
وارسال معلومات ماليه عبره
يعطيكم العافيه بصراحه اذا كان عدد سكان
كوكب الارض 8 مليار شخص ففي عندنا احنا
على التطبيق واتساب 2 مليار ااا حساب شغال
بشكل شهري
بالنسبه لتطبيق واتساب واستخدامه في
المعاملات الرسميه من حيث الشركات او
البنوك
والشركات لها سياسي خاصه في استخدام جميع
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل عام همم
بحيث انه الشركه او البنك بخاف من همم
تسريب المعلومات والبيانات اللي موجوده
همم
الموظفين لذلك بنلاقي انه في بعض البنوك
فرضت همم اللي هو غرام ماليه
يعني المعلومات هذه يرسلها موظف في البنك
الى الامير يعني معلومات ماليه خاصه نعم
فيها دي الحاله الا لماده تطبيق واتساب
كتطبيق لما هذا هو امن
جميل جدا الان المحادثات في واتساب مشفره
عن طريق الود تشفير التام خلينا نتخيل انه
اذا انا بدي ارسل رساله واتساب من تليفوني
بيكون هو عباره عن القفل الشخص اللي بده
يستقبل هذه الرساله همم بيكون كجههاز يعني
انا بتكلم الان على الديفايز هو معه مفتاح
هذا القفل لكن هذا التشفير همم غير كافي
لانه همم الشركات تخشى من الثورات التي
تظهر بين الفنيه والاخرى على هذه
التطبيقات على سبيل المثال همم لنفرض انه
قام شخص باستخدام واتساب من خارج المتجر
مثل الواتساب الذهبي او تجيبي واتساب وهذه
التطبيقات غير امنه لانه الاشخاص اللي
قاموا بالتعديل عليها قاموا بالتعديل
عليها همم على همم عن طريق اللي هو فيرسنج
باضافه اكواد
استاذ عباده
الا تكب الحريه الشخص يعني اليوم عندما
نتحدث عن واتساب اصبحت ليست وسيله ترفيه
وسيله تواصل نان بيد اس ام اس فبالتالي
الا تتعدى بها كذا قرارات الشركات على
الافراد وحرياتهم
بصراحه اللي حدث او اللي جعل انه هذا ال
ال الاجراء يصير انه في عام 2021 اعلن
واتساب انه سيشارك جميع معلومات
مستخدمين مع باقي ملصقات او منتجات شركه
مياه هو في الحقيقه مش اعتداء على حريه
الاشخاص او الموظفين لانه احنا اذا بدنا
نتكلم عن تطبيق مراسله وهو تطبيق همم ليس
للاعمال علما انه في عندنا نسخه همم
لكن همم لكنها غير مهنيه في التواصل مع
الاشخاص اللي بتتعلق بالبنوك وهمم وارسال
المعلومات الحساسه والتي يمكن همم
اعتراضها من خلال هجمات الامن الاستمرانيه
من اخطر هذه الهجمات اللي ممكن انه يقع
فيها مستخدمين للواتساب اللي هو سنك مش من
المنطقه انه انا اكون همم
ويقوم شخص بعمليه تصيد الاحتياليه يتكلم
معي بصفه همم جهه رسميه بصفه همم بنك همم
بيقوم همم سؤالي عده اسئله للحصول على
معلومات حساسه بقوم انا بتقديمها فجميع
البنوك وجميع المنصات التواصل الاجتماعي
همم باحضروا استخدام همم او همم استخدام
اللي هو منصات التواصل الاجتماعي في
التواصل مع عملاها حتى واتساب نفسهم حتى
فيسبوك حتى شركه انستقرام ما بتواصلوا مع
الاشخاص ومع الكستمرز الموجود عندهم عن
طريق منصاتهم نفسهم اغلب المحادثات واغلب
المراسلات بتكون عن طريق اللي هو يعني
الكتروني
على الكمبيوتر في كثير ناس هيك بتعمل اليس
هذا حلا متحايل بنفس الوقت
جميل جدا قبل عام تقريبا كان عمليه اللي
هو ربط الواتساب على الجهاز اللي هو
الحاسوب همم ما بيمر في مرحله
المزامنه التام لجميع
لجميع المحادثات الموجوده الى حساب
الواتساب اللي انا بملكه او الي بملكه اي
شخص بده يقوم بهاي العمليه لكن في الوقت
الحالي اذا انا بقوم بعمليه تشغيل
الواتساب ويب حتى لو كان الدي فاي او
الموبايل اللي موجود معي غير متصل في
الانترنت فانا باستطيع اني اتواصل عن طريق
الواتساب اللي انا بملكه على الواتساب لكن
همم تخوف الكبير انه احنا
همم يعني مش التطبيق نفسه والخلل بنخاف من
عمليات اللي هو الفيشنك عمليات لانه يكون
نفس الجهاز مخترق عمليات انه همم يكون في
شخص يتجسس علينا يعني هي كانها بشكل مطلق
عام لا يخص فقط المؤسسات الماليه ولكن حتى
العمل العادي مثل عملنا الايمان ده في هذه
الحاله نحن نرسل معلومات شخصيه نرسم
معلومات حساسه الى اما ادوات صب امن ومفيد
في عملنا العادي
بنستخدم شبكه الانترنت ما في شيء امل
نهائيا همم فلذلك لازم انه يكون عند
الاشخاص اللي بيستخدموا هذه المنصات الوعل
كامل بحيث انهم يدركوا انه قد يتم اعتراض
رسائلنا همم قد يتم قد يكون هناك طرف ثالث
بيقرا المحادثات تبعتنا قد يحصل على
معلوماتنا همم اشخاص يقوموا باهتزازنا
مستقبلا همم قد يتم استخدام كلمات المرور
والمعلومات الحساسه لاغراض همم تتعلق
بالهكرز لاغراض تتعلق
معلومات
العسكريه والقواعد العسكريه
لكن انا ما نتحدث عن الشركات في مبالغه
نوع ويبقى دائما الحديث همم
شكرا لك